i think we can all agree that counter-strike
global offensive is almost a perfect shooter
i repeat almost even an esport as tried
and tested as cs go has its fair share of
infuriating mechanics overpowered weapons and game
breaking bugs things that make you want to jump
out of your chair and curse the day that big daddy
gaben was born so today we're counting down our
top 10 grievances with cs go that make us want
to scream the top 10 things that are just well
kicking off our list we've got our
most controversial entry the op
i'm actually gonna i know i know how could i
possibly be talking smack about the mighty green
isn't it the sickest and most skillful
gat in cs go look the sickest sure but
skillful no even after getting nerfed back in
2015 the op is still kind of old one shot to
the chest from anywhere on the map through armor
is all it takes to delete someone from the server
and look no one is saying the ceiling
on this weapon isn't absurdly high
but the floor pretty [ __ ] low this thing
just thanos snaps you off the map a little
too easily and there's pretty much nothing you
can do about it and the pros agree they can't do
anything more to like nerf it you know because the
gun's broken like it is it's both like fully fully
[ __ ] to think that you can not be looking and
just do this and kill two guys he's like what the
hell man it's like it should it shouldn't be fair
you all better smoke that mid-cross cause for our
number nine entry we're shipping off to dust to
cs go's original dumpster fire i'm ready to go now
what is there to say about dust too that hasn't
already been said it is the oldest most exciting
and most enduring map that counter-strike has
ever known as well as inarguably the most iconic
battlegrounds in the history of first-person
shooters dust 2 is quite literally an institution
but it also really sucks sometimes planting and
under window under window under window under
the window god damn it kill him
godfather terry he just [ __ ] sucks
what are you doing whether you're getting flashed
into oblivion on long desperately trying to retake
b or just want to leave your [ __ ] spawn question
is can they actually get a kill initially yes they
it's no secret that sublime though it may be does
too can be an absolute nightmare to play oh back
to dust2 the land of cheaters i you know that was
my hypothesis my hypothesis was thus two cheaters
all right look you better start holding an off
angle because for the eighth spot on our list
we're setting up some cheesy ridiculous one ways
the one way smoke that i'm about to show you will
land on the window latch and will allow you to
peek through a small gap at the bottom right part
of the window while you being in the window can
easily spot any enemies at topmit they won't have
the tiniest chance to spot you in there hey look
i get it in a game as inaccessible as cs go where
utility isn't just learned but mastered knowledge
is power and creating a situation where you can
see everything but your opponent can't see you
is really powerful what you do you do the smoke
you do the flash i showed you and you do
the mall of firebox and you jump just here
you clear default and this year
he doesn't see you from ct here
and while i'm all for outwitting an opponent
sometimes things can get downright outrageous
oh this is dumb bro i thought
you're like seeing through the smoke
i mean oh it's not that bad yeah yeah yo yourself
follow yourself i'm gonna throw it on top of you
make your finals ball yourself by
yourself one way lane this is stupid
okay so for our seventh spot we're forcing up and
it'll be worth it why because you'll have a scout
i just worked chris jay's only got the scout
though but can you finish it off oh if he
hits the head he definitely can stay alive as well
dropping into sandwich but the push is coming down
as well as uh shut down one around from chris j
three with the scout all those the fourth as well
look i know this one's a bit of a spicy
take but hear me out picture a poor man's
op that does roughly 70 damage to the
chest is a one-shot head shot through
armor and has near-perfect no-scope accuracy all
for seventeen hundred dollars but the real kicker
is that you're a freaking speed demon whilst
scoped watch the stick strap right here
oh my god
well it wouldn't be of the score esports top 10
without the 1g for our sixth spot we're talking
about well just the confusion around molotovs
in general oh no from it no how fast do mollies
actually kill you do they do less damage through
kevlar or not why is their spread so inconsistent
how fast does it travel and how in god's name are
you supposed to figure out where the fire hitbox
actually starts look i'm not saying that mollies
are overpowered per se i'm just saying that the
number of times that i have died to one that i
didn't even think i was touching is a lot it also
feels like when i touch one they do a million
damage and i end up looking like this come on
all right um
just move on just move past it [ __ ]
my life coming in at the halfway point
of our list is a map that also feels
as if it were only halfway finished
vertigo would you remove vertical from the
map pool yes the map is trash remove it ah
vertigo the active duty pool's very own a-ramp
simulator a map so shoddily constructed they
needed to fix it not once not twice but nearly
10 times after reworking it midway through
the stomping grounds of one don hatchi himself and
bane of professional players everywhere closer and
closer to overtime the first player to fall on
land look i'll be honest i like vertigo and i
still think it is a cheesy ridiculous hellscape
where mid control doesn't matter and you don't go
b unless you have a death wish they're holding for
this mid play with the the boost or they're going
to go for the run boost it has to oh no rip shakes
he's annoyed about that one giving away his life
okay look if you're even remotely serious
about cs go you had to know that this one
was coming taking the fourth spot on our list is
the patently busted hand cannon that is the deagle
the fact that it can end someone from across the
map with a single headshot is fine that's what
it was designed for the issue is that it's also
god tier at close to mid-range with two shots
to the body through armor sealing the deal this
isn't exactly what i'd call difficult to master
up in main is the call they're going in although
and it's robs who's found them all only a deagle
required straight to the belt two clicks a piece
easy as that i don't give a [ __ ] how sexy or
skillful y'all think it is a 700 sidearm has no
business being this spammable and destructive
eeking our way into a close third
we've got a good old-fashioned classic
our game's one and only titular
annoyance getting cs goad
what what
what
i'm talking of course about those monitor smashing
moments when after catching someone off guard and
placing your crosshair smack dab in the middle
of their noggin you pull the trigger only to
find that csgo's shitty servers and spaghetti
code had other plans he still manages to deny
the plant though blast but gets dropped and
olefmeister now trying to find a way over here
pronax has managed to spot it what how is that
not a kill he looks dead on there salvaging the
previous rounds doing automatic will be boosting
up the hooks thanks decent incendiary all the bug
cs goes at its finest yep losing a gun fight is
one thing but getting deus ex maki knowned by
big daddy gaben himself there's just no recovering
from that it goes without saying that cs go is in
no shortage of idiots who use wall hacks but our
runner-up spot on this list goes to the times when
cs go decides to give the average innocent player
some wall hacks of their own i'm actually france
dude i'm actually [ __ ] dead what the heck
counter-strike has had plenty of see-through
smoke bugs over the years all thanks to the source
engine and the game's notoriously nonsensical code
the problem is more or less the source engine
source is really bad at handling multiple
transparencies layered on top of each other both
the semi-transparent smoke and fire could be the
reason why the bug exists if you've put any amount
of time into counter-strike there is a very decent
chance that you've smoked off a choke held it for
pushes and watched as the enemy becomes perfectly
visible through your utility too long one dead
that's clipped i gotta clip that like right now
that's i'm sending that to csgo at csgo on
twitter because that's their games bugged
now to be fair a ton of these smoke screw-overs
have been ironed out over the years that said you
can still occasionally spot dudes through a bloom
if there's an active molly behind it which like
is a pretty scummy way to secure a frag still
it's not as if you're not gonna shoot the guy
cs go is a hard game we take those taking
the top spot on our list is the single most
kw inducing croc of horse [ __ ] in the whole of
cs csgo the biggest baddest most mammoth-sized
cauldron of snake oil papa gaben has ever
sold us zack did emilio just get back banned
what what over the years valve's
proprietary anti-cheat has proven
so incapable of removing cheaters from cs go
that other esports have started to meme on it
nicely played mikasa yep very well
played oh the power shot from off screen
oh man i know people complain about vag but my
goodness the aimbot is real it doesn't matter
if you're walling toggling or just a full blown
raging spin bot vac is more likely to stonewall
you for trying to obs your in-game footage than
loading up an actual aim assist okay my this
isn't working and while valve has made several
efforts to improve their god-awful anti-cheat
like with overwatch and vacnet nothing has worked
i don't wake up in the morning wondering if i've
been banned even after a really cheap decouple
games because at this point i i just can't see
how i'm gonna get banned needless to say the vast
majority of cheaters in cs go unpunished so even
though cs go as a game is really quite healthy
and in arguably the best shape it's ever been
be sure to steer clear of matchmaking and stick
to face it well that's it the top 10 things
in counter-strike global offensive that are just
straight thank you so much for watching and please
let me know in the comments if there's anything
you [ __ ] hate about csgo see you next time